sur le site de la spa un triste
recensement 13000 12 c'est le nombre
d'animaux recueillis par les refuges spa
depuis le début de l'été un conte qui ne
cesse d'augmenter d'autant plus que les
adoptions ne sont pas au rendez vous
refuge d'orgeval dans les yvelines les
boks affiche complet on a le sentiment
que plus les années passent
effectivement plus loin après le coït
déjà l'année dernière quand les gens ont
repris un petit peu un rythme de vie
normal on a eu une hausse hibbert super
importante des abandons les demandes
sont quotidiennes malheureusement voilà
de d'abandon soit par téléphone par mail
ou monique des gens qui se présentent
aussi directement au refuge comme on a
très peu d'adoptions n'est pas forcément
capacité de pouvoir les accueillir
sachant qu'on a aussi les animaux qui
sortent de fourrière parfois aussi les
animaux laissés au portail kla
concrètement où la petite place on n'est
même pas en capacité malheureusement de
prendre tout toute la liste d'animaux
qui en sortie de fous rires
les propriétaires en cours 45000 euros
d'amendé et trois ans d'emprisonnement
pour un abandon mais cette sanction de
s'applique aux abandons sauvages au
refuge hors jeu valve il faut prendre
rendez-vous pour abandonner son animal
avec plus de 10 demandes par jour la
liste est longue et les motifs toujours
les mêmes les problèmes de comportement
de l'animal il ne cherche même pas à
avoir un éducateur canin qui pourraient
les aider les accompagner apte à
abandonner leur animal ou aussi bas le
déménagement je suis dans un logement
plus petit donc ces encombrants sont des
gens qui a car un animal sans se poser
les questions de ce que j'aurai les
moyens de subvenir à ses besoins est ce
que j'aurai le temps à lui accorder est
ce que je suis prêt à aux bêtises qu'est
ce que j'ai fait pendant les vacances
est-ce qu'on est en tension est ce qu'on
part avec est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
vient s'en occuper et c'est toujours
mêmes qui trinquent en fait c'est
l'animal ça c'est trois petits cochons
nains qu'on a récupéré ce week-end en
avant juin ce sont des personnes qui les
avaient pris en animalerie parce que les
enfants est là mais sauf que balle
arrive les vacances et qu'il n'avait pas
de solution pour les faire garder on a
des animaux qui vont vraiment dépérir
surtout chez les chats
les chats qu'ils arrêtent de s'alimenter
en abandon c'est assez fréquent les
chiens c'est moins marquée on voit où
sens à leur comportement après ça avec
des animaux qui risque de faire de
l'hyper attachement bizarre vie de leur
met aussi sur place une centaine de
chiens 70 chats et une dizaine de nac
attendent d'être adoptés